la vidéo est assez au vendredi dernier
qu était à cannes pour les nrj music
awards il présentait une émission
spéciale avec plein d'artistes et parmi
eux il y avait en jane et cauet a
demandé un petit service durant la pus
visiblement n'était pas chaude pour le
faire donc quand il a tâté à l'antenne
d'ailleurs regardez bien la tête de matt
pokora regarder de bahts
il y aura sera totale esi pourquoi je
suis là
allez-y sur le cul je vendais angèle un
petit bonjour une petite fille j'ai eu
le plus petit bonjour du monde
ah bonjour tu as demandé dire bonjour du
bonjour bonjour la vallée fallait un peu
dire dix jours comment ça va c'est la
base face à un message vidéo pour
quelqu'un c'est pas un message d'une
seconde c'est un message un peu plus
haut ça dépend bonjour et bienvenue dans
un bon jour
j'aurais dû demander de 8go ché pa
savais pas qu'il fallait demander comme
ça la seconde après un petit bonjour je
suis hyper d aller en infra situe oui
bah c'est pas pour moi c'est pour elle
mais effectivement si j'en vois un truc
très court comme ça ça moyen drama
refera way serait pas plus mal
alors comment ça va sinon est ce que tu
es prête pour demain dans la dernière
remarque c'est un peu trop soleil sa
venue depuis qu'une fois cinq secondes
c'est du second degré je pense non non
non non il a raison et il est chaud
froid du château rico et tu manges et
les choses qu'on s'aimait si c'est une
vidéo pour une gamme il est peu dire
bonjour ou de predrag à mixer à douzy
bonjour réclamé à s'arrêter je peux
comprendre qu'elle a c'est la page sur
lui c'est pas pourquoi il la vidéo c'est
pour la gamine c'est ça qui m'énerve
édition à laquelle c'était là ça a été
racontée comme ça enfin bon
[Applaudissements]
orange mais après j'étais très beau
autour d'elle aux nma des personnes
qu'on connaît ici en qui on a confiance
et on me dit que c'est une super fille
comme moi j'adore pour moi c'est la plus
talentueuse du monde et bien